there are new questions about two women
who say they were stranded on a sailboat
for months in the Pacific Ocean video
shows the dramatic moment when a Navy
ship rescued Jennifer Pell and tasha
fooi ova last week the Coast Guard says
the two had an emergency beacon on board
but they never turned it on
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is here with the details
this morning don't seem to add up the
lad good morning good morning the
boaters say they were on a journey from
Hawaii to Tahiti when they began
suffering one problem after another now
the details of their story are raising
questions
Jennifer Appel and Tasha foo Yaba were
overwhelmed with joy when the US Navy
saved them last week they say they'd
been floating helplessly in the ocean
for months desperate to be rescued we
had tears going down our eyes are like
okay but the sailors are under new
scrutiny as the investigation is turning
up unusual details the US Coast Guard
says the pair had an emergency position
indicating radio beacon or herb on board
it's a device that communicates with
satellites the scent of boats location
to emergency responders Annie perb works
when a boater manually switches it on or
when it's submerged in water if
something were to go down and for
instance you lost whatever emergency
gear you did have you have a life jacket
that's on and usually they have a verb
inside or some kind of stroke so that we
know where to find you the Coast Guard
says EPIRBs save lives
it did here in March 2016 when crews
saved two fishermen whose boat sank off
the Florida coast but it didn't help
Jennifer and Tasha because their beacon
wasn't activated the women claimed they
suffered crisis after crisis after
slamming into near hurricane-force winds
they say part of their masts broke their
engine flooded and their communication
system failed them Coast Guard Petty
Officer Tara mall said we asked why
during this course of time they did not
activate the e perb Appel had stated
they never felt like they were truly in
distress like in a 24 hour period they
were going to die but in front of the
crew of the USS Ashland Appel said the
opposite had they not been able
locate us we would have been dead within
24 hours a pal now says in retrospect
there were two instances where she
should have used the e perb the Coast
Guard is investigating the circumstances
surrounding this incident but says there
is no criminal investigation underway
right now CBS News reached out to both
women and we have yet to hear back from
them I don't want to doubt this story
vladica sure that women survived and now
Marines going mm there are some
questions bummer
thank you glad thank you